joe biden is putting gun control on the
ballot this november the president
calling for a slew of anti-gun measures
during a highly politicized primetime
address
biden demanding congress act but only on
the gun crackdown policies that he
supports instead of trying to find
common ground the president taking the
opportunity to bash and blame
republicans
but according to a new poll the majority
of americans don't agree with biden over
half don't see school shootings as a
guns problem but that's not stopping
biden from trying to strong-arm congress
into doing what he wants
for so many of you at home
i want to be very clear
this is not about taking away anyone's
guns
we need to ban assault weapons in
high-capacity magazines
and if we can't ban assault weapons then
we should raise the aids to purchase
them from 18 to 21.
the fact that the majority of the senate
republicans
don't want any of these proposals even
to be debated
or come up for a vote
i find unconscionable
i believe the majority of you will act
to turn your outrage into making this
issue central to your vote
enough enough enough
but that's not good enough for some on
the left here are the ladies of the view
i always say um don't vote for
republicans because right now i mean you
can go back to it
after we get gun laws so i'm now with
you joy
get rid of republicans get rid of the
party
um the party as it stands now because
it's the party of white supremacy it's
the party of insurrectionists it's the
party of uh
massacres at this point it's the party
that you just
wow
how do you even how do you even come to
a question based on that greg i mean the
party of massacres the party of
insurrection the party of white
supremacists um and
even before i get into that i mean the
fact that biden says the republicans
don't even want to debate don't we have
cornyn a republican trying now to work
out a deal with the democrat yeah at
ford's it's being politicized but yeah i
mean it's it's when you listen to sunny
you have to understand this is the
dumbest person on earth i mean she's a
lawyer right imagine her argument in a
court case where she goes to the judge
i don't think it's fair that i have to
argue this case with the other side can
we just lose can they just lose their
legal team and i'll just take it from
here because that's exactly what she's
saying she goes i don't want to actually
hear an opposing or a shared opinion or
debate i'd rather just get rid of all of
them and then she smears them the thing
is
again it's all about the svt single
variable thinking you can't trust
somebody if they're only focused on one
variable and that's what you saw last
night with uh president biden uh and
that's why people can't trust them
because they think that oh my god if
they're only focusing on one thing they
are coming for that one thing and that
is guns it's all about curbing social
media focusing on mental health uh
not pronouns and optional identities and
it's also about security for schools and
we can talk about guns we are
open-minded the republicans should
actually go for it and talk about a
multifaceted approach to protect
children and take the lead and say look
we're open to everything because the
democrats can't expand their viewpoint
but republicans can
joe though could cut you remember he
said that second amendment isn't
absolute he could cut the gun-toting
population in half if he announced that
all democrats will forfeit their second
amendment rights and turn in their guns
half the country you know if you think
guns are evil then why don't you give
them up first take the first step you
guys lead and we will follow i mean a
lot of climate activists will do that
they'll reduce their own carbon
footprint
they won't own a car so maybe democrats
who don't like the second amendment get
rid of the guns
probably a lousy shot anyway all right
kellyanne you know there is no question
that even 51 percent of americans agree
that you know guns are not the the
answer to the school's massacres the
school shootings that we're seeing they
see other components they see mental
health is a problem they're interested
in strengthening the schools why isn't
congress whether it's the democrats or
the republicans or both of them why
aren't they focused on all of the issues
just like greg is saying as opposed to
guns guns guns guns and by the way there
is one congressman who said spare me the
bs although he said the full words about
constitutional rights
well he said that he also said spare me
the bs about mental health that other
countries have mental health problems so
they don't have guns and there you've
got joe biden and others like senator
cornyn the republican task to work on
this and the senate judge who are
talking about mental health why because
even the congress even the american
rescue plan last year 1.9 trillion
dollars has 112 billion earmarked for
schools in a post-covered world so
instead of ventilation systems and the
stickers on the floor and masking
seven-year-olds that money has been
earmarked for counselors for mental
health services and for lost learning
this administration has already admitted
that it's an issue but if he can go on
prime time and not talk about the
children his first mistake talk about
the guns
he is a non-credible messenger
it is a white house that lies from the
podium you've had 13 high-profile
departures in the first female first
first vice president of caller's office
they don't want to work there these
dream jobs have been turned into
nightmares and and frankly they don't
have a messaging problem they have a
fact problem and he joe biden talks as
if he just got to washington yesterday
he speaks as an outsider when everybody
knows he's in his fifth decade this is a
guy who was tasked by president biden
after newtown after the sandy hook
massacre in 2012. joe biden was tasked
sorry joe biden was tasked by president
obama to work on this nothing got done
so when he says do something he's
incapable of doing that i think we
should look at
look there's never any one reason so you
can't have anyone's solution and we have
to look at the profile of a lot of these
shooters
someone like that who the other students
are afraid of them take them seriously
here in new york see something say
something is about backpacks on the
subway you're afraid of a of a student
we that that needs to be important the
guy in um nicholas cruz the guy in
parkland the fbi had been to his homes
so many times and never did enough and
there he was aspiring to be a school
shooter if you aspire to be a school
shooter you're going to get your wish
well you know well one of the things
that
we talked about yesterday was with the
coveted lockdowns kids in schools now go
kind of like from sixth grade uh to
ninth grade because they missed two
years and they are emotionally
not mature enough is socially uh but now
they're they're in a position where
they're with older kids i kind of tie
that together with the fact that since
2018 we are now seeing the mass shooters
the age of the mass shooters younger and
yuvaldi uh and and and uh uh is about
not buffalo is it buffalo yeah
and 19. um you're absolutely right judge
if you were honest and sincere about
trying to address this problem you would
be addressing all of the multi-factorial
contributors that you and greg and
kellyanne are pointing to guns are but
one part of that equation mental health
as you've mentioned isolated social
media first person video shooter games
big pharma all of our kids are being
prescribed drugs at absolutely record
rates and you're going to tell me none
of this is contributing to this uptick
in yes younger shooters but the focus
has to be simply on the gun when you say
do something when president biden says
do something he means do something about
guns and i will just say the people that
are the most passionate about gun
control are simultaneously the most
dishonest and ignorant people about guns
they know very little about caliber or
velocity or magazines they use these
terms weapons of war or assault like or
assault weapon exactly right greg they
used these terms like they learned them
yesterday on the back of a cracker jack
box they have functional meanings or
they're made up in either case and they
do nothing nothing to solve this problem
all right uh harold what about the fact
that there are 20 congress people in
swing districts democrats who say why
don't you break this bill down so that
we don't have to vote on yes or no on
guns even they're worried about the
public
not necessarily buying into the second
amendment destruction
so look i i agree with a lot that's been
said but
i approach these things differently we
have a problem
right we've since sandy hook the
shooting at sandy hook there's been 900
mass shootings in the country now
they've been nine or five or three or 14
i'd say you know maybe there's some
overreaction they've been 900. are those
two how do you define those though
harold a mass shooting yeah because they
change they keep changing them like it's
like four i know this i don't want to be
a part of one yeah i can look it up here
i can google it we can google with a
mass shooting
number two
number two because every organization
i'll let you tell them so let's just say
it's more than two that's gotta be
that's gonna be more than one so 900 of
them
two
in these in these situations the school
stuff i would agree with you the guns
alone are not the problem with these
school shootings but in buffalo the gun
probably was a bigger part of the
problem in the mental health as well
i think democrats have to be willing and
republicans have to be willing to accept
a little of what they don't want if we
want to try to solve this problem
because it is a problem this is not
something we're making up their kids
being killed they're people
in tulsa oklahoma you had a hospital
frontline workers be shot by a patient
who was upset by the care and treatment
that he got so i do three things one the
age of the shooter ought to be 21. two
we ought to have a longer background a
period for a waiting period for the
background checks to take place so if
there's big tech stuff if there's social
media things let's figure these things
out investigate can i can i just finish
look i know i know these are
uncomfortable things but i'm glad that
it's uncomfortable i just know that in
real time you are not going to get law
enforcement to do that i used to sign
these permits i was lucky
to check if they had a record you hire
more people democrats also have to
accept well i don't i don't give up like
i sense there's a there's a resignation
here number three a genuine curiosity
you got to put trained people in schools
with guns so you know how to use them
absolutely not teachers yeah not
teachers can i just
listen to your suggestions
listen to four of you guys tell me and
i'm just trying to react to
conversations
what i'm trying to say in the spirit of
a conversation is i actually for one
would be open to listening to you
talking about raising the age of buying
an assault weapon from 18 to 21. i'd be
willing to have that conversation well
conversations have to be had okay they
have to be had on honest grounds and
again
go ahead harold we have a problem in
this country right and it's not going to
be solved with what you all have just
said you know why because we've been
doing that all along and it's still
happening it's not going to be solved
with just democrats talking about guns
you guys want to bash democrats fair
it's a good it's about no they're
bashing us
now listen to me i'm only well i'm i
wouldn't be saying anything if one for
good faith my friend i mean i'm telling
you what i'd like i call balls and
strikes on democrats all right
but harold no no no no no no no aids
should be raised there should be a
longer period to explore someone's
background they have a 28-day waiting
period i'll show you that may be too
long we ought to do that we ought to
have uh we're gonna have school in the
school situation armed people at these
schools and i believe it's a controversy
but the these ghost guns we've got to
deal with that when we talk about these
gangs and other things chicago and new
york we're conflating some of these
agree with that coming up next joe
biden's presidency is failing so bad
that even the liberal media is turning
on him